عده الى اعلان الجيش الاسرائيلي مقتل
ثلاثه من ضباطه في معارك خان يونس في قطاع
غزه معنا مجددا من تل ابيب مراسله الجزيره
فاطمه خميسي
فطمه ضعي في صوره هذا الاعلان الجديد من
قبل الجيش الاسرائيلي ثلاثه من ضباطه على
ما يبدو قد قضوا في
غزه نعم ايمان اذا وفق المعلومات الاوليه
الوارده من الجيش الاسرائيلي فان الجيش
يعترف بمقتل ثلاثه ضباط اثنان منهما برتبه
رائد والثالث برتبه نقيب جراء المعارك
الدائره تحديدا غرب خان يونس نحن نتحدث عن
يوم شديد من ناحيه قتاليه في مناطق جنوبي
القطاع تحديدا في خان يونس كان هنالك ايضا
تطويق لتلك المنطقه بشكل كبير وتوغل
القوات الاسرائيليه ولكن المصادر
الفلسطينيه والاسرائيليه تؤكد تفجير
مبنيين وانهيار ثالث بقوات عسكريه
اسرائيليه ما اد ادى الى اصابه نحو 20 بين
قتيل وجريح والجيش الاسرائيلي يقول بان
ثلاثه قتلى وثلاثه جرحى اصيبوا في هذا
الحدث على ما يبدو طبعا هنالك رقابه تفرض
على هذا الحدث بشكل مؤكد ولكن وفق
المعلومات الصادره فاننا نتحدث عن ثلاثه
ضباط اسرائيليين قتلوا في المعارك الدائره
في خان يونس جنوبي قطاع غزه ما يرفع حصيله
قتلى الجنود منذ بدء هذه الحرب الى
535 جنديا والى 198 جنديا منذ بدء العمليه
البريه اذا ما اردنا ان نصف المشهد على
المستوى التطورات الميدانيه التي شاهدها
قطاع غزه اليوم نتحدث عن استمرار المعارك
الدائره ما بين الجيش الاسرائيلي وما بين
الفصائل الفلسطينيه المقاومه في مختلف
المحاور في قطاع غزه ايضا في وسط القطاع
كان هنالك غارات جويه استهدفت مناطق يقال
بانها تابعه لحركه حماس وانها مواقع ل
وبنى تحتيه عسكريه تابعه للفصائل
الفلسطينيه المقاومه ولكن غالبيه العمليات
العسكريه التي شنها الجيش الاسرائيلي
تمركزت في منطقه خانيونس وعلى مستوى
التصريحات الاسرائيليه سوف تتواصل هذه
العمليات التي تتركز في مناطق جنوبي
القطاع بشكل كبير هنالك ترجيحات بان قاده
حماس وعلى راسهم السنوار والضيف يتواجدون
في تلك المناطق و هنالك مؤشرات وفق الجيش
الاسرائيلي تدل على وجود الاسرى
الاسرائيليين المحتجزين في غزه في تلك
المناطق ولكن هذا الامر ايضا يتعارض مع
الروايات السابقه التي قالها الجيش
الاسرائيلي
بان الاسرى الاسرائيليين محتجزين في غزه
تواجدوا في مشفى الشفاء وفي مناطق الشمال
وعند اجتياح تلك المنطقه لم يحصلوا على اي
شيء وبالتالي هنالك يعني روايه اخرى يقوم
الجيش الاسرائيلي بتسويقها الا وهي ان
المعارك سوف تشتد في جنوبي القطاع لوجود
الاسرى الاسرائيليين في تلك المنطقه طبعا
مقتل هؤلاء الضباط في هذه المعارك الدائره
من شانها ايضا ان يعود وان ينعكس على
الشارع الاسرائيلي الذي يشهد احتدام شكرا